I have a very very special relationship
with Reagan and I have two little girls
at home the thought of breaking her
heart by not urging everyone to give
this girl a shot to go and and redeem
herself next week would be too far
beneath me so I gotta fight for my girl
and I got to make sure that I represent
her properly in this moment because she
didn't have a chance to use her voice
night last week Adam Levine have made
that plea to the voice viewers asking
them to save a singer Reagan strange who
was too sick to sing for her safety he
got what he asked for
Reagan stayed Walt fellow team Adam
contestant DeAndre Mikko got the boot
fans freaked out
accusing Adam of playing favorites even
DeAndre said he was hurt by the move it
was just weird cuz I just felt like not
being rude I just felt like he sold me
out you know
but and I just don't respect it just
being honest a week later here's what
Adam had to say about the controversial
decision it was a strange week but it's
over now DeAndre is my boy I love him
he talked it's all good viewers weren't
into that non-apology though trolling
adam on social media saying that they've
lost all respect for the coach we did
our job sick or not I just got over
laryngitis and I still when I came back
I still saying it wasn't another day
anxiety or none of that stuff I know
she's a little kid but it's like man
you could have put some words in for me
at all like some something it is a tough
thing to balance Adams been open with et
in the past about how he almost becomes
like a dad to his singers for sure for
me was one of the first times I ever had
I guess a platform that I could help
people out with and were like even be
that play a role at all as like a mentor
a mentorship really right you realize
you have things you can share with other
people it's not so much paternal as it
is just like you realize you your whole
life you've lived up to this point you
now have things you can reflect on and
help people that are coming up with
that's cool
[Music]